welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for Marvel's what if season 2
these Nine episodes are dropping one at
a time one after the other from Friday
December 22nd through Saturday December
30th so let's break down this trailer
shot by shop for details you missed and
what to expect from the second season
quick recap Marvel's what if season 1
came out in August September 2021 with
Nine episodes of what we thought were
part of an anthology series of
independent Marvel hypothetical
scenarios like what if Peggy Carter got
the super soldier serum what if tchala
became Star-Lord what if the Avengers
were killed off because Hank Pim turned
evil what if Doctor Strange became
strange Supreme what if zombies took
over the Marvel world what if kilmonger
rescued Tony Stark what if Thor were a
party boy what if Ultron won and really
these final episodes revealed that all
of these were really part of an
interconnected storyline in which the
Watcher assemble these Heroes into a
Guardians of the Multiverse team to
combat Ultron Infinity Whom The Watcher
and strange ultimately trapped in a
deadlock with killmonger infinity so
this show is not really a disconnected
Marvel Spotlight animated show that
doesn't matter it matters matters it is
MCU Canon and not just because P Carter
showed up in live action in Multiverse
of Madness since this is all headed to
Secret Wars any of these characters
could show up in live action so the
season 2 episodes have been confirmed as
follows December 22nd episode 1 what if
nebula joined the Nova cor December 23rd
episode 2 What If Peter Quill attacked
Earth's Mightiest Heroes December 24th
Episode 3 what if happy Hogan Saved
Christmas December 25th episode 4 what
if Iron Man crashed into The Grandmaster
December 26 episode 5 what if Captain
Carter fought the Hydra stomper December
27th episode 6 what if the Avengers
assembled in 1602 December 28th episode
7 what if Hela found the 10 Rings
December 29th episode 8 what if cahor
reshaped the world and December 30th
episode 9 the finale what if strange
Supreme intervened so a programming note
here my wife and I are having a baby and
the due date is December 20th new
rockstars absolutely plans to break down
each of these episodes and if we are
lucky to get like some press screeners
from the studio in advance we are going
to try to get some of these breakdowns
written and shot in advance so they'll
come out on time for you but you know
it's also going to be the holiday season
thanks Disney plus so a lot of our staff
is just going to be out during this time
but either way you can absolutely expect
to see some of these breakdowns from me
and some of them from someone else on
the new Rockstar team either the final
week of December as these episodes come
out or the first week of January but
we're going to get to all of them and
these are going to be great videos don't
worry you are going to see me on the
channel throughout the month of January
with some fun prescheduled breakdowns
and I'm going to be back later in
January full-time smelling like a diaper
okay this trailer opens with shots from
episode two what if Peter Quill attacked
Earth's mighty's Heroes basically this
story line is what if in the year 1988
Peter Quill actually met his biological
father of ego and acquired Celestial
Powers got assimilated with him and ran
a muck on Earth Earth's Avengers in the
80s will include Bucky Barnes the Winter
Soldier Hank Pim Ant-Man remember that
was a DH Michael Douglas from the
Ant-Man prologue Wendy Lawson StarForce
that's Anette benning's cre scientist
character from the 2019 Captain Marvel
film black panther king tachaka that's
tala's father from the 1991 prologue in
Oakland in Black Panther Bill Foster
Goliath and Thor so we see at a carnival
young Peter Quill wearing the same
Dolores river rafting shirt that he was
wearing when he was abducted in the
Guardians prologue that his girlfriend
years later was wearing when they
escaped Morag he takes this raccoon
plushy reminding us of Rocket Raccoon
and suggesting that this kid was always
destined to meet his furry trash Panda
buddy Hank pimp says that he's great
with kids as he does have a daughter
hope VY who would be around Peter's age
and then the Watcher narrates you
thought the story was over but it was
only just beginning I don't do sequels
normally but things have gotten a little
twisted in the Multiverse it's kind of a
meta commentary referring to most what
if stories in the don't really get
sequels it's not really part of like a
canonical future but this what if
animated series is kind of breaking that
rule we see Hela walking the rain up to
her antlered headpiece this would be
from episode 7 what if Hela found the 10
Rings it looks like she's in a crater
and in shuni we learned when wo found
the 10 rings in a crater but we never
saw that origin story Miss Marvel
suggested that the 10 Rings came to
Earth in a history that was linked with
the Bengal so maybe that was the crater
that they were found in and Hela as an
extraterrestrial ASG Guardian might shed
some light on what the 10 Rings actually
are now this shot of Hela legs in the
rain match Cuts with nebula approaching
an incapacitated yandu this would be
from episode one what if nebula joined
the Nova cour there's a quick shot of
the'80s Earth's Mightiest Heroes tachaka
Bill Foster Wendy loss and Hank Pim with
Howard Stark with a mustache and Peggy
Carter looking like their appearances in
the Ant-Man prologue Peggy as director
of Shield is going to be the kind of
Nick Fury figure to this team then we
see that dragon from shanii the great
protector who remember battled the soul
sucker aka the dweller Darkness this
would also be from the Hela 10 Rings
episode but notice his eyes are glowing
green so Hela probably is controlling
him the way controlled the wolf thin
reer in Ragnarok we see Wanda in her
Scarlet Witch Tiara but I assume this is
from episode 6 what if the Avengers
assembled in 16002 this is going to be
kind of the zombie horror episode of the
season it's adapting Neil giman and Andy
kubert's Marvel 1602 miniseries that
spun off the 162 New World Fantastic 4
and Spider-Man 1602 this is all set in
Earth 311 in this reality superheroes
appeared 400 years earlier starting in
Elizabeth in England and then this moved
on to the American colonies and we see
Marvel heroes hunting down witch breeds
that turn out to be mutants so W Vision
episode 8 actually showed us Agatha's
Coven in Salem in 1693 this animated
episode is going to show earlier than
that Wanda as an evanora type witch
Queen before Plymouth was even founded
so we might even get some hints that tie
in to Agatha darkhold Diaries that's
going to come out at the end of 2024 as
Wanda summons his blast of chaos energy
we see some others joining her I wonder
if these could be other female Marvel
Sorcerers who would be part of her
earlier coven it looks like we see a BAL
the ancient one there that might be lady
CF and orella joining her maybe frga is
part of that mix because fr was also a
sorceress oh one shot energy huh I think
I'll try
[Applause]
it so what is one shots Focus sh
do see
it eternity
wa so uh one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with oneshot
energy today by going to oneshot
energy.com neww rockstars for 10% off
your order there's a quick shot of The
Watcher back in that fifth dimensional
prism through which he watches
everything this is where Ultra on
Infinity first turned around and saw him
and broke through then some shots of
episode four what if Iron Man crashed
into the grandmas the visuals are
totally inspired by madmax Fury Road
it's a death race with Gamora and Tony
Stark and makeshift Hulkbuster armor
Valkyrie in a car that looks like the
cockpit of her ship in Ragnarok she
crashes that tall helmeted gladiator who
showed up in the party Thor episode last
season and we see corg and a little
rodent The Grandmaster Winks at his own
statue which Winks back this looks like
it was actually from the episode that
was planned to be in season 1 because
remember Gamora and Tony showed up
looking like this in N of leer with rri
getting the infinity Stone Crusher in
one of the later episodes then more
shots of Peter Quill versus the 80s
Avengers I think Peter will do to Earth
what ego did to his planet and
assimilated it into himself because
notice the Avengers are fighting an army
of Warriors made from dirt in the shape
of ego's Kurt Russell form and remember
when they fought ego in Guardians Volume
2 he kind of turned the rocks and the
terrain of that planet into things for
the Guardians to fight similar thing is
happening here ego Peter and Earth all
seem to be assimilated into one and I
just love the irony of that because ad
skirt Russell played mccre in the thing
and go watch my deep dive of that film
because I explained why mccre was really
the last human the alien would want to
assimilate into its communion more shots
from the Hella 10 Rings episode and then
the Nova cor nebula episode and then
wiwu and either xan or Ying Lee team up
to fight Odin then Steve Rogers uses his
vibranium arm Shields from Infinity war
to fight Thanos in the jungles of
wakanda Thanos here has all six stones
and in Infinity War Steve was never
close to him when he had all six Thor
was the only one who got close to him at
that point this might come from the end
of season 2 when like strange Supreme
intervened because it looks like Steve
is slicing the green Tim Stone on The
Gauntlet there so strange might be
looping back to this time Stone Centric
moment moment okay more from the 1602
episode we see Elizabeth and Hulk with
facial hair a hooded Ant-Man and
Elizabeth and cap fencing now whether
this is Steve or actually perhaps the
1602 Captain Britain Bill bradock we
will see I assume this guy's Shield is
going to Bear the English flag the Red
Cross and the White Field because that's
what it was back in 1602 it didn't have
the blue field of Scotland until after
Elizabeth died we see gamor taking
topaz's staff and Rocket hopping on the
shoulder of a dark elf rocket wearing a
sick bionic suit this actually looks
like the collector's Vault so could be
part of the Nova cor nebula episode
strange Supreme intervenes as we hear
I've been looking for you for a long
time and then the word time Echoes and
we see cordi and this is pronounced
kahor according to Ryan little who
produced this episode this episode is
going to explore what would happen if
the tessar fell to Earth and landed in
The Sovereign hosani Confederacy before
the colonization of America korti is a
real wolf clan name and it means she
stir in the forest or someone who
motivates those around her she's going
to join Captain Carter in the finale
crossover episode as they face Hela in
the shot we see cordi with the towers of
the space Stone opening a ton of space
Stone portals overhead kilmonger from
season 1 is going to return he's going
to factor into this finale as will
Thanos from some Dimension he's grabbing
Peggy's Shield here and it looks like
the stones are on the gauntlet but he is
not using them so maybe he is here to
help Peggy carrying a 1602 sword or
maybe just the sword that she got from
Red skull's castle in the very first
episode of the series she reaches into
this green Rift to grab the hand of who
I assume is 1602 wit Wanda the title
puts Captain Carter beside the Watcher
so truly Captain Carter The Watcher and
strange Supreme are really the main
characters of the series The Trailer
ends with happy Hogan calling Darcy in
the Christmas Eve episode episode 3 what
if happy Hogan Saved Christmas I love it
it's a DI hard parody Happy is in the
vents like John mlan was and remember
Iron Man 3 director Shane black was
known for action movies set at Christmas
time like Kiss Kiss Bang Bang the 2005
movie that definitely resurrected Robert
dowy Jr's career and was really what got
him the role of Iron Man instead of
nakatomi Plaza Avengers tower has been
overtaken on Christmas presumably the
terrorist whoever took it maybe the tin
Rings maybe Hydra or maybe with the
several drones putting a Santa hat on
the a logo these could be the iron
Legion drones and Ultron who overtake
the tower Happy's just a guy in the
wrong place at the wrong time he's stuck
on the inside and has to save the day
and he's calling Darcy like John mlan
called Reginal V Johnson's cop character
Sergeant Powell who also got that call
while he was on a snack run then we see
coming in at the last second to save the
tower is going to include Iron Man
Hawkeye Steve Rogers I think and I think
that's Natasha and a ballerina tutu we
know she can dance ballet she might have
been performing in like a Christmas
production of The Nutcracker and
speaking of John favro Christmas stories
one of the pre-shot paternity lead
breakdowns we're going to have plann is
a breakdown of 2003's Elf that was
directed by John favro it's a movie I
rewatch every Christmas and was arguably
the movie that proved to Kevin bige that
John favro could make Iron Man a hits
again more details to come on when
exactly we will break down each of these
episodes of what if season 2 and who's
going to be doing them but I'm so
excited for this season and to watch
each episode with my little baby in my
life follow me on all social platforms
at eaos follow new rock stars support
new rock stars by grabbing one of our
Loki inspired shirts at nerd rot. shop
thanks for watching I'll see you next
time
bye
[Music]